well here in the u.s a confederate  monument at the center of a violent  white supremacist rally in  charlottesville virginia  is gone from public viewing this morning  crowds clapped and cheered as the bronze  statue of confederate robert e  lee along with the second statue of  general thomas stonewall jackson  came down saturday they've been moved  into a temporary storage facility  now the city says it's looking for a  museum a military battlefield or  historical society to take them  their removal comes nearly four years  after violence erupted at the unite the  right rally leaving one person dead we  all remember that  president biden had previously weighed  in on this issue saying monuments to  confederate leaders belong in museums  not in public places